the executive director of un women there
head of international women's day well
we're going to talk about that with our
next guest but there's a lot of other
things to discuss
too the shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy joins us now from wigan thank you
so much for being
on the program this morning um i just
want to start with
the budget and one of the most
significant things to come out the
budget was this freeze and income tax
levels
now i was kind of under the impression
that labour supported that by reading
the observer that you're going to
vote against it can you clear up what is
labour's position
we are going to vote against it this
week we think that now is absolutely the
wrong time
to be targeting low and middle income
earning families for tax hikes and
squeezing their incomes not least
because
if you do that it means that they're not
going out and spending on the high
streets and the economy
the recovery is very fragile at the
moment we were really concerned when
those plans
were announced that what the government
was effectively saying was that low and
middle-income earning families would be
targeted
to start paying into the system a full
year before
many of those major corporations because
the corporation tax rise doesn't come in
until a year later the shadow chancellor
pushed the chancellor on that
um at the dispatch box we couldn't get a
satisfactory answer we think this is the
wrong thing to do so we'll be voting
against it this week
you said that shadow chancellor pushed
um
on this but at the same time it does
feel like it's been a bit of a change of
heart and you didn't oppose that earlier
in the week
and the shadow chancellor told my
colleague kate mccann on wednesday
it would have been the wrong decision to
do it now but more sensible to take
these measures in the future
i mean it is a year in the future it
feels like there's been a change of
policy here
is that a bit opportunistic
no we've been we've been absolutely
consistent about this that we don't want
to see
low and middle income earning families
paying the price for this pandemic but
just to come in here
just just sorry just to come in if i may
because you've made the point on low and
middle income and a few times and
yes i i accept that it will impact them
but it does
affect higher rate taxpayers more
doesn't it
it's not targeted it does but it it it
does but we've been consistent in saying
that the recovery
is very fragile there are businesses in
this country
including many in my constituency here
in wigan that just haven't had
they haven't been open for most of the
last year because we've been in almost
permanent
lockdown in parts of the north of
england and
what they most need to see is families
going out and spending again
when um when we start to unlock they're
looking forward to that they think they
can survive if we do that
but if you start to target those
families too quickly what you'll see
then
is the recovery choked off before it's
even begun we're also very concerned
about the fact that buried in the small
print of this budget
with a council tax rise for those
families we're going to see cuts to
universal credit coming in
in six months what you're what you're
hitting families with
is a perfect storm where their incomes
are going to be
squeezed from multiple directions and we
just think that that is the wrong thing
to do it's the wrong thing to do for
those families
but it's also the wrong thing to do for
the economy just wonder if it sounds to
some like a bit of a cake and eat it
approach
um you're voting against uh tax risers
you want to see
more public spending on things like
nurses pay for example
because you're also of course saying
that the government's planned one
percent payrolls for nurses isn't enough
what do you want to see well i don't
think this is a heavy cake and eat it
approach i think this is entirely in
step
with most major economies if you look
over at the united states
joe biden is putting in a fiscal
stimulus package worth trillions the
european union
is following suits i think there is a an
economic consensus
that the way in which we're going to get
through this
is to make sure that we protect
businesses and workers
right now and actually the you know
there was an argument about that in the
conservative party but ultimately that
is an argument that the chancellor
accepted by delaying
corporation tax rises in this budget we
want to see
money going into the pockets of low
earners hard working
low earners including lower middling
earners in the national health service
who deserve it who've got us through
this crisis
who've gone out and worked every single
day were promised a pay rise
and should get at the very least what
they were promised
and that is the way that you get the
economy moving again we saw that in 2010
when we had a
huge deep cuts to the public sector it
took money out of the pockets of working
people and it choked off
any prospects of recovery in towns like
mine we cannot afford to keep making
these mistakes again
the question was about nurses pay the
you say that the government's plan one
percent pay rise isn't enough
what pay rise do you want to see well
the government
to be clear is not planning a pay raise
the buried in the small print of this
budget was not only that
uh that what do you want to see i'm just
trying to work out
but i'm trying to work out what what's
labour calling for
yeah i'm just making the point that that
is a real terms pay cut because it
doesn't keep
pace with inflation and for nurses to be
offered a pay cut
is just reprehensible in our view the
in the nhs long-term plan the government
budgeted for a 2.1
pay rise that is what nurses were
promised and last year they legislated
for that
in order to give nurses a cast iron
guarantee that after years and years
of seeing their real terms pay full that
the government would finally
reverse that situation and start to see
their pay increase we think they ought
to go into these negotiations
at a bare minimum honoring that promise
of 2.1
and then considering what more they can
offer
to our nhs staff who have done so much
to put their families
and themselves at risk every day going
into work some of them have died
what can they offer to our nhs workforce
who've done so much
so what are you calling and above that
2.1 what do you
think at the very minimum yeah we think
at the very minimum they
they must honor that commitment that
they wrote into law
at 2.1 and then there is a process
ongoing where a pay review body
rightly looks at this independently of
government they will make
recommendations to government
but we think nurses deserve a pay rise
this year and that should never have
been something
that was up for negotiation this is a
government that's completely got its
priorities wrong
if they can give a special advisor who
broke the rules of 50
pay rise but then offer our nurses a
real terms pay cut
that is a government that just has not
understood who it is that is getting us
through this crisis
and who deserves to be fairly rewarded
the royal college of nursing says it's
preparing for
possible strike action would you support
nurses
striking well i'll always support
nurses i've always supported nhs staff
since i was elected
11 years ago but nurses in my
constituency who i met last week are not
asking me
for a strike they weren't promised a
strike they were promised a pay rise
and that is what i'm determined that
they're going to get a pay rise
and the resources for the national
health service that last year the
chancellor said would absolutely
categorically
be delivered he will he said we will
give the nhs
whatever it takes and instead buried in
the small print of this budget
was an eight billion pound cut for the
nhs they were promised a pay rise
there were promised resources for the
national health service and that is why
i'm determined to stand shoulder to
shoulder with
our nursing staff in order to make sure
that the government delivers
okay now children of course returning to
the classroom
tomorrow big news for pupils teachers
and parents of course
um in secondary schools teachers and
pupils are going to be told that they
should wear face masks unless they're
exempt
it's non-binding guidance though does
labor think it should be a legal
obligation i think all the way through
this health crisis when we've met with
sage scientists and had regular
briefings they've been absolutely clear
that you can't
enforce public health you have to carry
people
with you and i think going down a route
of enforcing
you know compelling students to
to take actions is probably not the
right approach it's not
the right approach for students for
parents and many teachers in my
constituents have been telling me that
they feel that that would be
unenforceable i think what we really
need to see is a wider
plan of action to help people comply
with the measures
on testing for example there are a
number of parents who are very worried
about their children
being tested one of the reasons for that
is because many parents can't afford to
self-isolate at the moment if their
child's test
comes back positive so we've been
pushing the government to extend the
self-isolation payment 70
of people who apply for it are rejected
and that's why
one of the reasons why only three and
ten people are actually doing it so
i think there are other measures that we
could take rather than trying to force
teachers to go around policing math
squaring and other measures in schools
that would actually be far more
effective
um now i'm keen to ask about nazaneen
zagari ratcliffe as well the british
mother
in jail in iran now her sentence is due
to come to an end
today but her husband richard basically
said he doesn't know what's going to
happen
do you have any intelligence on on what
is likely had to happen to nazaneen and
what should be done
i don't it's been frustratingly slow in
relation to progress
on this issue and when i met with
richard ratcliffe
recently it was clear how difficult this
process has been
the family are very keen to to continue
to have the support of the foreign
office but
i think i i can say frankly that there
just hasn't been enough focus
and enough effort not just on nazanin's
case which is heartbreaking
but also on the other british dual
iranian nationals who are
currently being held in iran
we need to see much more progress on
this i you know when i meet this family
i just feel that there's
there's not much more that they can take
of this to be honest and other countries
have made more progress
in getting their nationals home we need
to see a really concerted effort now
across government led by the prime
minister to make up for some of the
mistakes that he's made in the past and
to make sure that we get
nazanin home and other dual nationals
home as well
okay now of course it's international
women's day tomorrow and
it does feel if if you look at the data
that the pandemic has had a
disproportionate impact
on women particularly mothers 17 of
mothers have had to give up on work
during the pandemics 72 percent cut
their hours
mothers on the lowest incomes nine times
more at risk of losing their jobs
are you worried that the pandemic could
set back women's progress
in the workplace potentially by years
decades
i am worried about it one of the things
that we've seen
um over the course of this pandemic is a
rise in working from home that's
obviously
had a huge effect on people's ability to
deal with
caring responsibilities not just child
care but care for elderly parents
as well but there is a gap between the
numbers of women who intend to return
full-time to the workplace if they get
the choice
and the numbers of men who do and there
is a concern that that could continue to
widen those
inequalities you know the people who are
in the workplace far more visible
far more likely to be making decisions
far more likely to be promoted so i
think there's a risk that
as we come out of this we could see
those inequalities that have widened
already during the pandemic widen
even further i'm particularly concerned
that
women lack an obvious champion within
government
and that these issues that often end up
being invisible as a consequence i was
listening
to your last interview with real
interest it's fairly obvious that the
more women you have
at the highest levels making these
decisions the less likely it is that
women
become an afterthought in decisions that
are made
so i think this is something that the
government absolutely does need to take
seriously and start to address
talking about having women in leadership
roles it's 2021
labour still hasn't had a female leader
i know you round yourself but not only
that but when labour did try
you did try to be fair but when labour
members have gone to vote
in the ballot for their preferred
candidate a woman hasn't even placed
above a man i mean that's pretty
depressing isn't it
i think it is frustrating for labour and
i won't dress that up i found it
particularly frustrating in the
leadership contest to hear
you know some of the things that women
often hear in when they're putting
themselves forward for leadership
positions you haven't got the experience
it's not your turn
they were you know you don't look like a
prime minister
i wasn't the only person to hear those i
think becky long bailey
heard quite a bit bit of that and so did
the other other candidates who weren't
men that is really frustrating that's
something that i'm absolutely committed
that we're going to start to turn around
and change but i have to say that
you know since that leadership contest
working with kierstarma and angela
rayner
i know that's something they're
absolutely committed to we've got our
first ever
shadow female chancellor of the
exchequer i'm the first
um famed woman to ever hold the post
of shadow foreign secretary you know if
you look at labour's top team we've got
women in those
key positions and i just hope that by
being in those positions
and by standing up and providing a
strong challenge to the government and
an alternative
about how to bring britain forwards that
we are showing the way
that women can be in those leadership
roles and that you know ultimately that
that will change and that we will have a
female leader at some point
in the future not yet i should hasten to
add
but i'm not going to do that again just
to at some point
was watching just just to clarify
um but you know that it is important
actually that women
are in those roles when i was growing up
there were women in leadership roles
people like tessa jowl who went on to
become
a mentor of mine i cannot tell you how
much those women
matter in those leadership roles you
know people like diane abbott as well
really strong women who broke the mold
and and
and blazed a trail it really matters and
i'm absolutely determined that our
generation is not going to drop the ball
on this that we're going to keep seeing
progress
i remember during that labour leadership
contest you said at one point that you'd
quite like to see
queen megan i just wonder how you're
feeling
about the cup some of the coverage of
meghan markle and prince harry you're
gonna be watching the oprah winfrey
interview i feel like i absolutely
jinxed that i
should probably never have said it
because things have only got worse for
the royal family since
then and i have to say that i you know
my heart does go out to everybody
involved in this it's
difficult being in the public eye it's
particularly difficult when your family
is dragged into this and what i see when
i look at the royal family is a family
going through a very difficult time
all of it being played out in public
with maximum
publicity i think it would be far better
for them if they were able to to deal
with this privately
behind the scenes and and to be honest i
think it would be better for the country
as well
they're having a very hard time but so
are hundreds of thousands of families
in this country at the moment because of
covid i think that they're the families
that we ought to be focusing on
okay lisa and andy thank you so much for
being on the programme thank you